[Musique]
deny Robert
bonjour Nous vous interviewons
aujourd'hui pour une chaîne yoube qui
s'appelle ser
viiew je connais c'est vrai on voudrait
avoir vos réactions par rapport à
Charlie on a lu une partie de votre
bouquin
Mikan pourquoi vous avez écrit ce livre
là mais c'est un peu la phrase que je
mets en exerg de de Baldwin là qui qui
et on écrit des livres pour pour changer
la la la perception que les gens ont du
monde
et ce
livre-l était assez difficile à il y a
une longue période de maturation pour
moi j'y pensais depuis un moment mais un
livre c'est toujours une une rencontre
entre une époque un auteur et et et une
sorte d'électricité quoi il faut avoir
le il faut euh il faut sentir la la
musique dès le départ quoi et avec
moikan j'y arrivais pas pour des tas de
raisons euh j'y arrivais pas parce que
j'étais plein de de sentiments et de de
d'affection pour pour pour surtout pour
Cavana euh j'avais un peu de rancœur à
l'égard de de de de personnes qui
étaient dans dans le dans le
livre et donc il fallait que je trouve
un une méthode très sèche et très
factuel de raconter cette histoire et
donc ça ça demande une énergie et et un
un regard et une profondeur et et je
l'avais pas et puis après les attentats
je pense qu'un des déclics a été de voir
que ce que je considère comme étant des
usurpateurs occuper les médias et
occuper le terrain et je me suis dit
qu'il fallait que je que je raconte
cette histoire l'histoire que je
connaissais de Charli Hebdo et d'arakiri
et cette histoire de de la presse mais
au-delà d'une histoire de presse c'est
l'histoire d'une marque charlido est
devenue une marque commerciale et je
voulais
raconter sa captation
raconter les détournements et tout
toutes les les les coulisses de cette
histoire et et en faire un un récit les
Américains appellent ça du New
journalisme mais en tout cas un récit
écrit et ci et faire en sorte que cette
histoire parle à tout le monde quoi donc
pour appeler pour appeler à notre
communauté à nos auditeurs qui est deny
Robert deny Robert c'est le
whistleblower français de la banque qui
a eu énormément de de petits aléas avec
des ubiciers des procédures votre
intégrité n'est plus approuvée j'ai
envie de vous poser une question qui est
Cavana et qui sont les
usurpateurs Cavana sans Cavana on serait
pas là vous S est pas là une partie de
de de tout ce qui'est la presse libre
sur Internet tout tout ça on le doit à
cet homme c'est-à-dire que dans les
années 60 lui et et son son alterego son
acolyte qui s'appelle George Bernier
dans le dans le le surnom et le nom
connu est le professeur churon donc à
deux ils ont créé la la première et à
mes yeux la plus importante aventure de
de journaux et de presse libre de de ce
pays voire de la planète c'estàdire que
les déficheurs de la voilà il y a eu il
y a très peu d'équivalents sauf aux
États-Unis les les les expériences de de
Free Press ou de choses comme ça qui a
eu dans les années 60 tout qui a
accompagné le mouvement un peu Hipi là
on a eu une presse qui a émergé qui
allait à contre-courant de de la presse
américaine installée il y avait deux
mouvements en fait en parallèle qui
était les États-Unis et la France mais
la France avait une grande spécificité
qui était cet humour bat
qu'on inventé Cavana et Choron et donc
c'est ces deux personnes kavana était le
et d'ailleurs dans dans mon livre il y a
une phrase de vilem qui dit il y avait
un malin et un intelligent churon était
le malin Cavana était l'intelligent
Cavana était celui qui écrivait qui
concevait et churon était était le
l'ingénieur de tout ça celui qui a
ramené l'argent qui avait un certain
génie pour l'écriture mais cétait
vraiment Cavana qui se bagarrait qui
avait les mains dans le camboui et et
dans l'encre et et qui inventait qui
avait inventé ces ces journaux et
surtout qui s'est battu contre la
censure parce que il est ils ont pendant
25 années ils ont eu trois présidences
différentes euh ça vous c'est très loin
pour vous mais c'est Charles de Gaulle
Jean Pompidou et Valérie Giscard destin
et chaque fois ils ont eu des problèmes
avec la censure mais c'était pas des
petits problèmes c'est-à-dire que ils
risquaient la prison on on on on
interdisait les les l'affichage et la
vente des journaux sous prétexte que ça
a attenté à la jeunesse et donc pour eux
ça était une bagarre permanente et quand
je dis qu'on leur doit tout c'est-à-dire
que la liberté qu'on a aujourd'hui on la
doit à ces gens-là et on leur doit même
plus parce que moi je je fais partie de
ces gens euh comme je sais pas Edgar
Morin ou d'autres qui pensent que sans
eux il y aurait pas eu mes 68 en France
et pas en tout cas un M 68
aussi ce qui s'est passé à ce moment-là
qui était aussi un mouvement précurseur
je je je sa je veux pas parler de ce de
ce qui s'est passé ensuite quoi mais ce
sont eux qui ont déverrouillé débloqué
la la la société française et au-delà
les des journaux en Europe en Angleterre
en Allemagne en Italie on ont existé à
l'image de de ces journaux là et donc
moi je je raconte de
l'intérieur des années 60 à aujourd'hui
comment ça se passer quoi d'abord ce
qu'on leur doit il y a toute une partie
du livre sur ce qu'on leur droit cette
bagarre contre la contre la censure
parce que ça ça se passait c'est j'ai
j'ai j'ai trouver des travaux
d'historiens et cetera vous avez dans
dans le Journal Officiel trois lignes
qui interdisent un journal et et et
voilà vous avez plus le droit de de de
le sortir là le premier numéro des
rakirie interdit C en 61 et et et 25000
exemplaires qui sont fait et ils savent
plus quoi en faire et donc ils ont passé
presque une année avant que le le numéro
suivant ressorte d'abord il fallait
trouver qui censurait vous racontez vous
racontez quelle était la commission de
censure l'entretien avec la commission
ouais qui est surréaliste quoi et il
sont face à d'abord un un fonctionnaire
de ministère l'intérieur puis après avec
un un un magistrat qui en fait c'est une
censure morale quoi le type il a le
journal et il compte les bits les les
les les toutes les phrases il critique
les dessins des dessins de Topor qui
aujourd'hui valent des fortunes en en en
salle des ventes vous avez un magistrat
qui trouvait ça noir et dégueulasse et
qu'il fallait pas passer ça et et donc
Cavana en fait plutôt avec beaucoup
d'intelligence
et en retenant churon qui avait envie de
jouer au bour pif il il il il va
convaincre ce ce magistrat de du fait
que ce sont des bons garçons que il vont
se corriger et cetera et la la pendant
la première interdiction ils vont faire
pendant une année 10 10 en fait en fait
7 numéros sur 10 mois uniquement à un
exemplaire ou à deux ou trois quoi pour
pour ces ces magistrats pour pour
montrer P blanche pour pouvoir ressortir
àakir et et et arakiri ne va ne va faire
que que que que grimper en
qualité et et en notoriété et à un
moment ils vendent 250000 exemplaires
par mois puisque c'était un mensuel et
puis ils deviennent
hebdomadair après après 68 bon c'est
toute une aventure de presse et donc on
leur doit beaucoup quoi qui a usurpé ça
alors ce qui ce qui s'est passé c'est
que au début des années 90 euh
né un
un Charlie Hebdo s'arrête en
1982 et pendant 10 années il se passe
rien il y a des petites initiatives en
France comme comme l'idion international
mais ça rentre ça rencontre pas un grand
public contrairement Charlie hebbdo qui
qui qui qui vendait beaucoup et qui
marchait très bien et puis faute de
lecteur et puis l'usure du groupe fait
que ça s'arrête un jour et à ce
moment-là en en donc il se passe 10
années et en 92 né un nouveau journal
qui s'appelle la Ros Berta qui était en
opposition à la guerre en Irak et qui
réunit beaucoup de dessinateurs dont la
plupart des anciens de Charlie Hebdo et
vers la fin Cavana et un type qui
s'appelle Philippe Val est dans cette
équipe là et avec Kabu ils vont avoir
ils vont se fâcher avec l'équipe de de
de la grosse Berta et ils vont décider
de ressortir un journal ce qui est
complètement légitime et eux étaient sur
une ligne plus politique plus
journaliste que la ligne bête et
méchante de de original et ils vont donc
sortir un nouveau journal s'il l'avait
appelé tartonpion il y aurait aucun
problème il y aurait pas de d'histoire
et pas de livre aujourd'hui simplement
ils vont l'appeler Charlie Hebdo et si
vous voulez c'est c'est à mon sens c'est
la première usurpation c'est-à-dire que
on la grosse Berta vendait on va dire
autour de 15000 exemplaires l'exactement
le même journal la semaine suivante en
enlevant grosse Berta et en mettant
Charlie Hebdo ça vend 180000 exemplaires
sauf que c'est un peu comme le le le
Canada drive quoi ça a la saveur de de
l'ancien Charlie hebbdo mais ça n'est
pas Charli Hebdo mais jusque- là à la
limite pourquoi pas quoi il y a des
détournements de marqu des choses comme
ça sauf que sauf que ce journal va va va
petit à petit dériver à mon sens quoi et
dérivé dans quel sens dans le sens
où l'idéologie de de de ce fameux
philibal va petit à petit prendre le pas
sur tout le reste il va faire des des
éedito favorable à la guerre en Irak il
va être il va faire passer ses idées il
va faire rentrer ses ses amis et des
gens qui pensent comme lui dans le dans
dans ce journal il va virer les récales
citron je raconte plein de de
d'histoires donc dans un journal qui a
l'apparence de la liberté de parce que
c'était des génies les types qui
créaient charliebdo il y avait de la
créativité il y avait de l'innocence ils
avaient fait un journal qui était
magnifique et ce type c'est un peu comme
un coucou qui rentre dans un dans dans
le nid d'un autre et il va en faire un
un un instrument pour lui au fil des ans
au début il était je dis tout ça s'est
fait progressivement il y avait pas un
plan préconçu mais si si vous voulez moi
moi je je je démarre cette histoire de
nos jours c'est-à-dire j'essaie de
comprendre les problèmes qu'ils ont
aujourd'hui indépendamment de l'attentat
parce que l'attentat a troué le ciel et
le livre est complètement étranger à
l'attentat il y aurais pas eu de livre
s'il y avait pas eu d'attentat mais je
prends l'équipe aujourd'hui et l'énorme
problème qu'ils ont puisque Charlie est
devenu une marque planétaire et j'essaie
de comprendre d'où vient l'origine de
ces problèmes et un peu comme en
psychanalyse je je je pense que c'est
tout le linge sale et toute l'histoire
qui n'a jamais été racontée qu'il faut
que je raconte tous ces secrets qui
n'ont pas été dévoilés et ces
détournements qui sont en fait le le le
le fait de de principe de plusieurs
personnes mais principalement deux
personnages Philippe Val qui est vous
devez le connaître il est il est le il
il chanteur non un ancien chansonnier
oui qui voulait être léopéré et puis qui
c'était son rêve qui est le fils d'un
d'un boucher charcutier de de nei et qui
euh voilà et qui était chansonnier et
qui et qui va se prendre pour un
philosophe quoi euh ou pour un homme
politique qui était un un un ambitieux
un type qui a soif de pouvoir mais qui
euh qui a mes yeux euh c'est sans doute
une des un des plus grands usurpateurs
que j'ai jamais vu quoi parce qu' en
plus il est intelligent il sait écrire
mais mais je je je pense démontrer dans
dans mon livre à quel point il est s
fois Ilois quoi et à quel point ce qui
compte pour lui c'est le c'est le c'est
le pouvoir l'exercice du pouvoir et
c'est le c'est il a il a tous les
défauts de de de ces ambitieux qui
arrivent sans grand talent mais grâce à
des réseaux et et ce que je lui reproche
indépendamment du détournement de fond
parce qu'il y a de l'argent et cetera
mais c'est d'avoir détourneré le fond et
le sens profond de ce journal et d'avoir
grimper comme ça dans la hiérarchie euh
et dans la hiérarchie de ce pays on va
dire en marchant sur la tête et en
écrasant la beauté l'innocence et la
créativité de génie comme Ryer Cavana et
d'autres et en abusant de de de de la
faiblesse et de la vieillesse de de
Cavana vous parliez de réseau est-ce que
vous pouvez me décrire ces réseaux
est-ce que vous les connaissez bah les
réseaux euh les
réseaux c'est c'est
euh oui je je c'est-à-dire que c'est
assez troublant de voir que dès qu' une
pétition dès qu'il y a des des soutiens
on revoit toujours les mêmes personnes
la maison d'édition Grassé Bernard Henry
levville le journal causeer c'est toute
une
bande de de gens comme ça qui il y a un
premier cercle et puis ensuite il y a il
y a tous ceux qui ont fait allégance ou
à qui ont rendu des services des renvois
d'ascenseur et cetera quoi et là
aujourd'hui il bénéficie de de l'aide de
l'appui de d'une d'une chargée de
communication qui s'appelle Anne Homel
qui est était la la la personne qui
s'était occupée de la come de de Cahusac
de de de deoscan d'Omar Bongo et qui est
une une femme assez
puissante également à mes yeux sans
foanillois et qui voilà qui fait tout
pour protéger cette bande c'est des gens
qui se cooptent entre eux qui veulent le
pouvoir et qui qui qui qui égrassent
tout sur leur passage et qui ont des
entrées dans toutes les télévisions les
journaux et cetera quoi et donc voilà
moi je suis le spectateur je suis pas
comment dire mon état d'esprit et ni ni
la revanche ni la colère ni tout ça je
suis quand même assez épaté par par la
force et la puissance de ces gens-là
quoi parce que par ailleurs mohikan qui
vit sa vie de livre plutôt bien
d'ailleurs c'est il est sorti avant les
attentats enfin il est sorti il y a 3
semaines maintenant et et euh grâce à
Internet grâce puis au bouche àille
c'est un bouquin qui qui a réimprimé qui
marche donc je suis pas là pour livre
par vous vous parliez de
de psychanalyse
ouais avec les attentats on a pu
voir un moment très puissant et ce
moment très puissant a pu générer une
décompensation estce que cette
décompensation c'est matérialisé au sein
de cette équipe est-ce qu'il y a eu un
problème avec cet argent qui a afflué
massivement de Google jusqu'à le citoyen
qui se passe dans dans cette équipe moi
je suis pas dans cette équipe euh mais
euh c'est très compliqué évidemment il y
a l'attentat la mort de de tous ces amis
de de ces qui on peut pas se mettre à
leur place c'est une déflagration c'est
comment vivre après avec ça mais il y a
le problème de de il faut continuer et
moi je ségé à des types comme ris ou
d'autres parce qu'il fallait que le
journal continue il fallait pour des
raisons à la fois symboliques politiques
et et parce que l'arrêté c'était
c'était c'était donné raison au taré qui
sont rentrés avec leur kalashnikov mais
donc le j'ai pas de problème de fond
j'ai pas de problème d'ailleurs avec
avec le journal on n'est pas obligé de
lire un journal quoi simplement je sais
que dans l'équipe en fait il y a deux il
y a deux courants enfin il y a deux
blocs qui s'opposent il y a la direction
qui est représenté par un ancien
comptable qui a 30 % DESP aujourd'hui
qui s'appelle éic Porto et par Laurence
sourissau don le dont le nom est ris qui
est le patron de ce jnel qui a 70 % des
des parts puisqu'il a repris les parts
de de Charb et en faceit vous avez une
rédaction qui perd de plus en plus
d'élément puisque Pelou et Patrick Pelou
est parti Luz est parti ils essaient de
virer par tous les moyens une fille qui
s'appelle Zineb voilà et vous avez une
équipe qui baisse les bras parce que la
la direction est complètement sourde
malgré la communication qui est faite au
au aux demandes et aux requêtes de de de
cette équipe en fait cette équipe qui
sont sont une quinzaine peut-être une
douzaine aujourd'hui ce qu'ils veulent
c'est créer une société des rédacteurs
et avoir droit à
à à à faire le journal qu'ils ont envie
de faire quoi qu'il a un partage du
pouvoir dans ce journal et vous avez une
une une direction qui est représentée
par l'avocat Richard Malka qui est
toujours en coulisse et par ris et
compagnie qui eux restent arbouté dans
leur dans leur précarré qui est on était
les actionnaires on a le pouvoir et on
veut faire le journal qu'on qu'on veut
quoi et donc il y a y a il y a plus de
communication entre eux vous en avez
quelques un qui soutiennent la direction
et d'autres qui veulent comment comment
se positionne le ministère de la Culture
par rapport à ça bah le ministère de la
Culture a joué les pompiers euh c'est
grâce à eux que le journal a pas explosé
quoi parce que parce que tout le monde
il y avait une une une une vraie bagarre
à l'intérieur de ce journal et ce que je
trouve assez troublant c'est que cette
histoire de société des rédacteurs
c'était exactement le même problème
qu'avait l'équipe des anciens en 92
quand il recrée Charlie hebbdo ils
veulent créer une société des rédacteurs
et et Philippe Val Marie cabrette qui
est la fille qui qu'on retrouve
aujourd'hui là-bas euh leur laisse
croire laisse leur laisse entendre que
ça va être possible et ce que je raconte
dans le livre c'est qu'il y a un avocat
qui s'appelle que j'ai retrouvé qui
s'appelle Bernard d'artevel qui lui est
sorti des radars que que personne et qui
qui avait comme stagiaire Richard Malka
quoi et dartevel est un est un militant
un partisan de la de cette société des
rédacteurs en gros pour qu'un journal
soit libre et et et que les journalistes
s'y sentent bien dans des journaux on va
dire normaux entre guillemets une
société des rédacteurs doit avoir une
part au capital peut-être pas la
majorité mais une part au capital et et
Charlie
Hebdo a fait croire pendant de TR années
qu'il voulait faire ça et en fait ils
ont réussi à à écartter cette société
des rédacteurs à capté le titre de de
acavana la captation s'est fait dans des
avec des moyens que je décris dans le
livre qui qui sont pas très qui sont
moralement euh euh
pas bien quoi enfin c'est c'est dire que
Cavana était le fondateur le créateur le
génie qui a monté tout ça et il va se
retrouver dans un journal où il est plus
rien il est il est il est plus
actionnaire il est pigiste quoi et en
face vous avez Philippe Val qui se prend
des gros
salaires gr sal euh à la fin il avait il
gagnaé 14000 13900 € et Cavana Cavana il
gagnait combien Cavana il était pigiste
à 1800 €. mais il avait parce que quand
même c'était tellement énor moi dans
votre bouquin dans votre bouquin il y a
il y a quelque chose qui m'a qui m'a
blessé c'est l'attitude du journal face
à à Cavana et au fax vous savez nous on
a une chaîne de hackur et et je je me
suis projeté dans dans ce vieux bureau
que vous décrivez très bien avec cette
cette chaise en paille avec Cavana qui
écrivait encore à la main qui ne
maîtrisait pas et qui préférait écrire
avec sa plume et il envoyait le ses
chroniques par fax et le fax en 2010
tombé en panne et on lui a pas changé
son fax ouais c'est le signe que il
était contrairement parce qu'on se
servait de lui comme une comme une
vitrine et une potiche quoi et donc et
donc quand le fax et on pane on le
remplace pas donc il doit se débrouiller
pour pour Contin continuer à écrire ses
chroniques et lui continue à les écrire
parce qu'il est il est il est graphoman
quoi il écrit tous les jours mais c'est
aussi son Gagnepain quoi parce que à
cause de de de la gestion de churon il a
pas de retraite et donc il les les 18
100 balles qui touche 2000 balles l'aide
et en plus il a c'est ce que lui a
octroyé ce ce que lui lui ont octroyé
Philippe Val et l'avocat Malka 0,4 % sur
les ventes du journal qui représente bon
an Malan entre 10 et 20000 25000 € les
les années où le journal vend bien qui
qui complète ça il a aussi des droits
d'auteur mais les droits d'auteur enfin
voilà il a un train de vie il a des
enfants et cetera c'est pas quelqu'un
qui dans la pauvreté mais quand on on
fait le le ratio et le rapport entre
entre des types qui se rincent parce que
il y a il y a le le problème de l'argent
est quand même important dans cette
histoire c'està dire que il touche des
de Philip valal je fais le descriptif
dans mon bouquin il touche il va toucher
plus de 2 millions d'euros entre les
loyers la la SCI qui crée c'est
charlibdo qui qui qui payent les loyers
et puis les l'argent gagné avec les
numéros sur les caricatures et cetera il
se partagent quand même beaucoup
d'argent et à côté vous avez des types
comme Cavana qui qui qui ont que dal
quoi et qui se font même voler il se
fait même prendre le le le titre
d'arakiri alors il y a tout un procès
mais je veux pas rentrer dans ces détail
comment comment le livre Comment le
Livre a été perçu par Charlie par
l'équipe de Charlie en général alors moi
j'ai des j'ai des très bons retours de
de de de trois personnes qui m'ont écrit
pour me de l'intérieur du du journal
mais mais il y a rien de d'officiel
parce que c'est un bouquin qui les gêne
la difficulté du livre c'est un livre il
arrive 9 mois ou 10 mois après les les
les les attentats euh
et je pense que avant c'était que
c'était pas possible parce que c'était
pas audible parce qu'il y a un côté
sacrilège de que de s'attaquer à Charlie
hebbdour mais moi je m'attaque pas à
Charlie hebbdo je je m'attaque sans
doute aux usurpateurs qui on ont fait ce
qu'il est devenu aujourdhui estce
Charlie est-ce que Charlie aurait pu
s'attaquer à Charlie non parce que il y
a d'abord l'actuelle direction c'est
toujours la même équipe qui était qui
était autour de Philippe Val et on voit
bien que Philippe Val essaie de revenir
dans dans ce gen all là et que et qu'il
arrête pas de dire dans les déclarations
qu'il fait que ris c'est son successeur
et ris ne dit ne dit jamais un MTH euh
contre Philippe Val et ça ça fait partie
de mon incompréhension parce que dans
mon enquête j'ai évidemment essayé de
prendre contact avec ces gens-là je
leuri écrit euh ils ont ils ont refusé
de me me parler euh et ça m'a déçu de la
part de ris parce que je vois pas
j'étais j'avais aucun a priori à son
égard quoi et j'avais des vraies
questions à lui poser par exemple par
exemple euh comment se fait-il
il qui quand il reprend Charlie Hebdo
euh avec Charb Cabu et et et et Val lui
laisse le journal était assez florissant
grâce aux caricatures et tout c'est un
journal qui a toujours été hyper
bénéficiaire les journalistes ont été
très bien payés et puis là quand il lui
quand Val lui vend il y a un trou de
presque 500000 € de déficit ouais parce
qu'entre-temps ben ils ont pris les
dividendes ils ont vendu l'appartement
et ils se retrouvent avec un journal où
il y a où il y a pas d'argent quoi et la
gestion était quand même un peu alors il
y a pas d'illégalité mais on est
toujours à la limite quoi et et et
comment pourquoi comment ça s'est fait
et ensuite tous les procès qu'ils ont
fait à Cavana dont personne n'a jamais
entendu parler je pense à Ris j'avais
toutes ces questions là à lui poser et
et ris m'a envoyé un mail en disant
qu'il met enfin il mettait en doute mon
intégrité et il a refusé de me me
répondre j'ai publié une partie de sa
lettre dans mon livre et et si vous
voulez l'autre l'autre réaction qui est
quand même assez troublante c'est celle
de Philippe Val et de Richard Malka qui
ont fusait de me voir et qui m'ont
envoyé des courriers d'avocat c'est dire
que l'avocat Malka a pris une avocate
pour me répondre des lettres dont je
publie des extraits aussi des très
longues lettres où il ne répond pas à
mes questions mais il prend un ton un
peu ironique comme ça pour pour tout ça
mais bon à la limite c'estette bonne
guerre mais ce que je trouve ce que j'ai
pas trouvé du tout de bonne guerre c'est
la la c'est le courrier que mon avec mon
éditeur Bernard barreau on est très
complice depuis 30 ans donc Bernard est
très important pour moi enfin c'est
c'est plus qu'un éditeur c'est c'est un
ami donc il y a pas on peut pas nous
séparer lui et moi donc c'est pour ça
aussi que j'ai fait le livre à Juliard
chez Juliard parce que je savais que ça
poserait des problèmes mais Juliard
appartient à une maison mère qui
s'appelle edditis qui possède une
trentaine de maison d'édition et donc
euh euh une dizaine de jours après le
courrier recommandé que j'ai envoyé à
Philippe Val j'ai le la maison d'édition
le service juridique de d'edditis a reçu
une lettre de George kigem qui écrivait
au nom de Richard Malka et de et de
Philippe Val en disant dans la letre let
disait en substance vous avez un auteur
qui s'appelle Denis Robert qui est en
train de commettre un livre profondément
diffamatoire on vous prévient en gros il
demande pas l'interdiction du livre mais
il laisse entendre que ils ont intérêt à
faire gaffe parce qu'ils vont déposer
des plaintes et c le même type de
procédure bon que vous avez subi sur cl
stream et ouais c'était un curieux
remake mais qui si vous voulez j'ai
trouvé pas ça très intelligent parce que
contraire à ce qu'ils ont imaginé à
l'intérieur du groupe de Juliard ça
s'est su qu'il y avait cette lettre et
les gens étaient scandalisés donc il y a
eu autour du livre un un un sorte de de
de mouvement de protection quoi et donc
alors après le problème c'est que j'ai
eu c'est que le livre a été lu
relu par des par des avocats ça m'a pas
gêné puisque moi j'ai pas envie d'être
diffamatoire j'en ai assez j'ai assez
donné dans la question donc ça m'a
permis d'être encore plus rigoureux que
je l'avais déjà été vous avez jamais été
diffamatoire
non non ça l' il y a eu il y a eu tout
un il y a eu des pressions qui ont été
faites sur un des un un de mes témoins
qui est l'avocat d'artevel qui me
parlait le Conseil de l'Ordre des
avocats de Paris a fait pression sur lui
donc ça a été très compliqué mais ça
c'est pas à moi en parler c'est plus à
lui donc j'ai le livre ça a été très ça
a été assez dur et et et la veille ou
l'avant-veille de sa sortie j'avais
j'avais fait état de cette lettre de de
kijem dans dans l'épilogue du livre et
on m'a demandé de l'enlever alors
j'aurais pu me braquer et dire dire non
monter sur mes grands chevaux il y a
quelques années j'aurais peut-être fait
ça quoi parce qu'on avait essayé de
censurer un de mes premiers livres qui
était pendant les affaires les affaires
continues et j'étais allé chez un autre
éditeur mais là je me suis dit c'est pas
grave ce qui compte c'est que le bouquin
sorte et que ma parole reste libre et ça
n'est pas un service juridique d'une
d'une d'une multinationale qui va me me
me me faire peur quoi parce que il y a
des liens entre service juridique et et
l'avocat en question enfin bon et tout
ça si on rentre dans ce processus là on
s'en sort plus quoi c'est là où on
s'autoocensure et tout à un moment donné
il faut être un peu intelligent donc le
livre est sorti mais il est
sorti avec toutes ces difficultés là
quoi et c'est assez épuisant de de
d'avoir cette pression là en en
permanence j'ai l'habitude mais je pense
que si ça avait été un autre que moi et
s'il avait pas eu cette relation avec
avec Bernard barreau ce bouquin serait
jamais sorti chez chez J personne et non
et c'était et ce que je raconte aurait
aurait été inaudible et et en tout cas
c'était très important pour moi de de de
faire savoir de faire connaître une
autre histoire de Charlie et de Charlie
Hebdo d'autant que la marque devient
comme je le disais tout à l'heure
planétaire donc il était vraiment
important que les gens sacheent que en
disant je suis Charlie comme tout le
monde l'a dit il y avait il y avait
vraiment une histoire qui était très
différente de celle qu'on raconte et
être Charlie ce que je raconte dans le
livre c'est que je suis Charlie moi je
le suis à la manière de Godar parce que
Godar suit Charlie du verbe suivre et et
et moi je serai jamais le Charlie de ces
usurpateurs mais je suis Charlie j'aime
l'esprit de Charlie Hebdo
euh même si aujourd'hui je trouve que le
journal mais je peux pas le en faire
grief mais c'est pas un journal qui est
formidablement écrit et dessiné il y a
toujours des choses intéressantes mais
dans le climat dans lequel ils font
c'est difficile surtout si les meilleurs
se barrent quoi donc voilà mais le livre
ne porte pas sur ça mais alors et après
il y a eu toutes les difficultés de la
sortie où je me suis retrouvé face au au
rouleau compresseur ça je pensais que vu
comment dire la mauvaise image de de
Philippe Val et et tout ce qu'il avait
fait comme comme erreur et comme
connerie à France Inter je pensais que
les médias mainstream on va dire ne lui
déroulerait pas le tapis rouge comme ils
le font dans une méconnaissance et une
amnésie totale de de de tout ce qu'il a
fait quoi tu as été sur pardon bon allez
tu as été tu as été surpris euh de ça
mais regarde comment sont traités les
les attentats à l'heure actuelle le PAF
n'invite que la la laquirrielle d'expert
classique et et tu es encore surpris par
ça nous sur Internet on n plus surpris
du tout de cette méconnaissance des ça
que c'est oui parce
que j'ai j'ai c'est peut-être ma naïveté
mais je fais et moi j'aime les gens je
fais confiance aux gens et cetera euh je
te donne un exemple qui qui peut-être
euh j'étais invité au moment de la
sortie de de Clear stream et et du film
de de de début d'année au Grand Journal
par
maena Biraben maena Biraben elle
m'invite avec des tréolos super accueil
ils font ils font un
et et quand le livre
sort donc on est 6 on est 8 mois plus
tard quoi je le Grand Journal me
réinvite euh en me demandant une
exclusivité enfin il passe par mon
éditeur et et donc c'était normal et si
ve à ce moment-là j'étais invité dans
d'autres émissions le livre devait
sortir et
donc évidemment on accepte l'invitation
parce que un livre il faut qu'on en
parle quoi et de TR jours avant d'aller
à cette invitation parce qu'on était
invité ailleurs et qu'il avait cette
exclusivité on essaie de
savoir quand enfin et là on apprend que
je suis plus invité donc et t'apends ça
comment je l'apprends par
par mon attaché de presse qui sur mon
insistance a téléphoné à Canal parce que
je peut-être je suis naïf mais je sais
que cette fameuse Anne omel dont j'ai
parlé tout à l'heure qui est une
directrice de communication et cetera
est aussi très proche de Boloré qui qui
et elle est la tachée de presse ou la
directrice de communication de Charlie
Hebdo mais aussi de maena Biraben mais
ma naïveté je je me dis cette maena
mirabed elle a quand même tu vois je
l'ai rencontré elle a même un peu de de
libre arbitre elle est capable où il y a
une rédaction en chef ils ont quand même
un minimum d'autonomie dans ce truc et
et vu la manière dont elle s'est fait
enfler par Philippe Val 6 mois plus tôt
quand il a sorti ce bouquin merdique qui
s'appelle malaise dans la culture il lui
a menti enfin et cetera il y a j'en
parle dans mon livre je me dis bon elle
va quand même être mais non mais pas du
tout c'est-à-dire que ils vont me
désinviter ils vont dire et ils vont
inviter Philippe Val tapis rouge et
cetera parce que c'est cette femme
fameuse directrice laacom qui en fait
choisit les invités du du Grand Journal
j'en ai rien à [__] du Grand Journal
d'ailleurs pour moi c'est quand je vais
dans ce genre d'émission ce qui m'arve
ce qui m'est arrivé assez souvent j'y
vais jamais avec plaisir j'y vais parce
que c'est mon travail parce que c'est
important de parler des livres mais j'ai
aucune comment dire aucune propension à
m'exhiber dans ces dans ces médias là je
déteste aller sur les les chaînes tout
info où on n jamais le temps de
développer une pensée une idée et cetera
je suis parfaitement conscient de de la
société du spectacle dans laquelle on
est mais j'ai rien trouvé d'autre quand
tu écris un bouquin avec ton chie pour
l'écrire ça fait 3 ans que tu penses qui
tu habites en permanence tu as envie de
que que un maximum de gens le lisent et
tu as pas d'autres moyens je suis
content d'être sur cnervview mais tu
vois je veux dire euh quand voilà les il
faut les utiliser aussi les médias il
faut y aller c'est un combat permanent
quoi et là j'ai j'ai vu mais ce qui est
vrai pour Canal ça s'est passé pour Le
Figaro pour le point pour L'Express pour
itél pour BFM pour par
le mec en question Val et partout et et
personne lui pose aucune question il
fait les les les ouvertures du matin je
décris quand même dans mon livre
précisément
l'usurpation j'explique d'une manière
très
factuelle comment ça se passe mais il y
a aucune question lui est posée donc si
tu veux j'ai pas de colère mais j'ai un
effarmement devant la la c'est même
c'est à la fois de la bêtise de la
paresse de de de de de des journalistes
de de ces médias là puisqu'ils ont des
cartes de pr il faut les appeler comme
ça mais mais bon il faut qu'il tu pens
est-ce que tu penses pas que
c'est une sorte de
propagande de propagande euh oui au sens
où shomski le dit c'est ça tuasas sans
doute mais un moment il y a une vraie
responsabilité des journalistes il y a
je pense à je sais pas je Thomas Sotto
par exemple je les connais pas moi ces
gens-là je le vois interviewer Val Jean
Lebrun je crois il s'appelle sur France
Inter pareil c'est des types qui ils ont
pas d'excuse quoi c'est des gens qui
s'ils font ce métier là ils doivent
s'informer avant avant d'inviter des
gens quoi et c'est pas possible de de de
faire ce qu'ils font quoi on a reçu sur
sur ce même canapé les deux journalistes
qui sont fait censurer sur Canal plus
sur le le reportage sur le Crédit Mutuel
ils nous ont fait remonter des
informations que on savait déjà nous sur
internet sur cette autocensure sur le
fait que les journalistes ne faisaient
plus correctement leur travail quel quel
bilan toi tuen tires mis à part ton sur
l'intégrité de la presse à l'heure
actuelle en
France tenu tenu par des gros groupes
Industri je crois pas je crois pas au au
complot je crois
pas
conérér parce que ces gens-là dès que tu
les critiques ou dès que tu émets un
avis défavorable ils sont tout de suite
leur leur leur rhtorique et leur réponse
te taxe de de de conspirationniste et
que ils sont libres dans les médias qu's
occupent et cetera c'est ridicule ils
sont la liberté c'est c'est d'abord un
choix individuel et et et et et c'est
leur premier senseur c'est c'est eux
c'est pour ça que moi un jour j'ai
démissionné aussi de libération c'est
pour ça que j'ai le parcours que j'ai
quoi on est on est on est on n'est
jamais irresponsable on est toujours
responsable de sa vie de ses actes de
ses papiers et et quand ils sont honteux
parce que là certains nombres sont
vraiment honteux euh il faut le dire
quoi et c'est mais ceci dit c'est pas
pour ça que je vais comme comment dire
même si parfois je suis dégoûté
arrêteter de regarder la télévision ou
que je la regarde quand même pour me
renseigner pas pour m'informer mais ça
me donne des les informations je les ai
évidemment sur internet mais des fois
pour voir où ça en est pour apprendre
des trucs j'étais fasciné par j'ai passé
ma nuit aussi pendant les attentats de
de regarder enfin tu vois il y a drogue
trait médiaque comment tu as été fasciné
par ce traitement médiatique exactement
pas
par pas par par ce qui était dit quoi et
j'ai j'ai trouvé d'ailleurs c'était
bizarre parce que pendant moi j'avais
mes filles qui étaient euh qui étaient
dans le quartier donc
euh donc il y a eu des moments l'une
l'une de mes filles a même été enfermée
dans une cave un moment c'était c'était
très chaud pour elle et et et donc euh
moi je découvre les attentats en pendant
le match de foot je suis avec mon fils
on regarde le match de foot et je vois
que Hollande se barre et tout et euh et
donc je je vais sur sur internet et je
et j'apprends très tôt par Facebook euh
euh l'histoire du du Bataclan parce qu'
il y a eu des des des machins et tout et
je me dis [__] c'est chaud j'appelle
une de mes filles et elle elle avait
elle devait aller manger au au petit
Cambodge parce que c'est sa cantine elle
et et et donc elle y était elle y était
allé la veille et elle me disent mais
non papa il se passe rien et tout et tu
tu elle pensait que je me moquais d'elle
je dis je assure c'est faites gaffe
enfin et cetera et au moment où on se
parle il y a des sirènes et ça commence
et tout mais il est 22h 22h15 22h30 tu
vois et après je je regarde tout ce qui
se passe sur Facebook il y a des et et
et je regarde en même temps itéé BFM je
[__] ils sont toujours sur sur la tèse
des 8 ou 10 morts ils sont hyper
prudents je pense qu'ils ont ils ont
c'était le contrecoup de ce qui s'est
passé en janvier mais ils vont avoir 2h
de retard sur la gravité totale de de de
de ce qui est en train d'arriver quoi et
et ça j'ai trouvé ça assez assez
troublant quoi en tout cas dans dans le
rapport qu'on peut avoir l'information
quoi ils sont fait un petit peu taper
sur les doigts quand ils avaient eu le
terroriste dans l'hyper cacher au
téléphone donc à mon avis ça a dû leur
laisser quelques petites
séquell mais tu vois par rapport à au
terroristes et au conversation moi je
j'ai réfléchi à ça et je pense je je
pense je je fais confiance à
l'intelligence des spectateurs plus qu'à
l'intelligence des des médiateurs et et
quand un terroriste appelle pour
revendiquer pour pour pour dire que
c'est bien de buter des gens enfin qu'il
a un discours tellement
délirant je je pense qu'il y a pas de
prosilitisme dans le discours et que et
et qu' il ça dépend je me suis pas
retrouvé dans cette situation où il faut
tout de suite transmettre le le document
mais c'est un document et j'ai pas à
obéir à ce que me dit le ministère de
l'intérieur ou de la défense et à pas
diffuser je suis un média libre
indépendant je suis journaliste un
terroriste m'appelle pour revendiquer un
truc c'est mon problème est pas de faire
plaisir aux terroristes ou de faire
plaisir à l'état c'est de de considérer
euh en écoutant la formation et ça me
dérange pas de la balancer parce que
c'est tellement délirant non mais en
fait si je peux si je peux me permettre
de te couper euh ils ont balancé des
informations au moment où le le le r ah
oui non mais ça je suis d'accord
évidemment quand le le mec était planqué
encore ça c'est n'importe quoi mais
c'est pas le problème c'est pas ce que
je veux dire évidemment ça il faut faire
super faire gaffe c'est comme filmer des
cadavres non c'est c'est le le parce que
là j'ai entend j'entendais routel CRIF
dire que ils avaient eu des appels aussi
qu'il avaient pas passé et cetera mais
c'est vraiment parce que le ministère de
la défense ou de l'Intérieur leur avait
interdit mais mais je trouve que que que
justement ces prédicateurs et cetera moi
j'ai beaucoup appris sur l'état de la la
folie de ces enfin on dit la folie
d'ailleurs faudrait s'interroger sur le
terme j'ai beaucoup appris sur ces je
sais pas comment les appeler j'ai plus
de nom pour pour les djihadistes là en
regardant des reportages sur la RTBF
mais qui sont passés en 2013 en
2012 il y a un reportage qu'on peut
retrouver sur Youtube ça s'appelle je
l'ai mis sur ma page facebook charia
fort
Belgium avec l'augmentation des partis
politiques en Belgique c'est ça non
c'est pas ça c'est on a des prédicateurs
qui se baladent dans Bruxelles dans
mollenbeck et qui ont un discours de
guerre mais mais et et et donc le le
journaliste c'est un peu traité à la
manière de striptiesas un peu comme ça
le journaliste les les fait parler quoi
les types tu les vois il y a des il y a
un père qui explique à un gamin le gamin
de 3 ans enfin le le il lui parle des
armes il lui dit que c'est pas bien
d'écouter de la enfin toutes les
conneries qu'on entend aujourd'hui pas
bien d'écouter de la musique une femme
tout tous c tous ces ces soi-disant
est-ce que est-ce que tu as essayé de te
mettre dans leur tête justement je je en
écoutant ça tu c'est c'est très int
c'est c'est là où moi j'ai un vrai
problème par rapport à ce qui se passe
quoi parce que je je j'y pense en
permanence évidemment quoi et comment le
le problème c'est comment rester une une
une conscience éveillée dans ce dans
cette multiplication d'informations j'ai
pas grandchose à dire sur le sur le
sujet sinon
que je n'ite je n'agite pas mon drapeau
je je je n'ai pas été victime
personnellement mais je je pense que les
bougies ne servent à rien que la
compassion
euh c'est c'est c'est ça fait du plaisir
aux gens mais moi ça va quoi et je pense
aussi que euh est-ce qu'on est en état
de guerre je pense pas qu'on soit dans
en guerre parce que pour être en guerre
en état de guerre il faut avoir un état
en face et je pense pas que l'État
islamique soit un état c'est je sais pas
ce que c'est l'état islamique mais en
tout cas je sais qu'il existe de notre
responsabilité de la responsabilité des
pays occidentaux de la responsabilité
des États-Unis des Russes aussi de la
politique au Moyen-Orient et cetera je
dis des des évidences quoi mais c'est
c'est notre création c'est c'est c'est
pas des évidences pour tout le monde
quand tu vois manuel vas qui dit il nous
attaque parce que nous représentons la
liberté d'expression la France on peut
se balader cun nu avec du ketchup et une
petite
plume alors que ceux on en a interviewé
plusieurs sur sur notre chaîne YouTube
puis on a un réseau aussi dans le
renseignement ce de terrains disent
clairement que c'est les répercussions
de nos frappes aériennes pendant 15 ans
avec les les l'IRAC Afghanistan les
mensonges médiatiques qui a créé des
névroses chez ces garslà ces névroses
ont été récupérés par des gourous ces
gourous ont été instrumentalisé et
financé par certains services pour
déstabiliser certaines régions et ça
donne ça maintenant le chien s'est
retourné contre son maître je suis avec
toute la profondeur de leur névrose non
non mais je suis d'accord mais après on
a un autre problème c'est un peu comme
toute proportion gardée avec le Front
national à un moment donné quand quand
on invite le Front national on on le
crée aujourd'hui il a 30 40 % tu es
obligé de le traiter différemment de la
manière dont tu le traitais avant
aujourd'hui on a un [__] de problème
dans ce pays qui est la la la
propagation de ces typesl qui sont
capables de frapper n'importe où et tout
le temps et et et et des services de
renseignement qui étaient à la ramasse
qui le sont toujours un petit peu donc
le fait de que je ne considère pas qu'on
soit en état de guerre ne ne ne comment
dire ne mésestime pas le problème on est
quand même dans une dans une situation
hyper dangereuse et et je j'ai j'ai
envie d'être protégé avant avant tout et
donc euh tu es prêt tu es prêt à
sacrifier tes libertés pour être protégé
alors sur le déb sur le débat de la loi
sur le renseignement si tu veux répond à
ma question est-ce que tu es prêt à
sacrifier tes libertés pour plus de
sécurité ou j'ai pas j'ai pas de
problème essentiel par rapport à ça sur
la loi sur le renseignement euh je veux
pas en discuter dans dans le détail
parce que c'est très compliqué mais je
suis pas opposé si veux moi qui suis
journaliste et qui était quand même en
permanence et é filé par la DST par les
officines tous mes téléphones étaient
écoutés et cetera je me suis toujours
démerdé
pour trouver le téléphone d' copain tu
vois donc c'est pas je vais pas
aujourd'hui pousser des grands cris
parce que il y a c'est c'est si tu veux
ce maillage et cetera parce que je suis
très conscient d'un autre problème qui
est celui de l'absence totale de cadre
juridique dans le cas de cette de cette
guerre en tout cas contre contre les
djihadistes qui sont France ou les types
qui se retrouvent
et si tu veux le le le le le problème
qui qui qui existait et qui existe
toujours c'est c'est comment tu fais tu
as une information tu sais qu'un imam ou
qu'un type se réunit au fafond de
l'Auvergne ou ou n'importe où dans dans
une montagne et que des types arrivent
et cetera il faut les écouter il faut
les surveiller il faut les arrêter il
faut voir ce qu'ils font mais il y a pas
tu vas voir un juge ça prend TR il a le
cadre juridique est pas possible donc il
y a il y a la nécessité de de donner au
militaire ou de donner aux policiers des
possibilités d'All écouter ces gens-là
de les surveiller et de les goer quoi
parce qu' il y a plus que ça aujourd'hui
et donc c'est pour ça qu'il fallait
créer une loi sur le renseignement qui
donne la possibilité à ces à ces
militaires de de de de faire ça et donc
pour arriver à ces informations là bah
il y a a y a une nécessité d'écoute et
cetera alors après c'est tout le
problème du contrôle de tout ça mais moi
en tant que journaliste je je suis pas
là à crier avec tous mes confrères qui
généralement n'en font pas du
journalisme tu vois tu pens est-ce que
tu penses que ceux qui surveillent les
surveillants sont suffisamment intègres
non alors non il y a un problème de
surveillance des surveillants comme il y
a un problème de c'est pas antinomique
ce que tu viens de me dire là non parce
que mais entre deux mots je choisis le
le le
moindre tu connais cette cette phrase
très connue un peuple qui est prêt à
sacrifier sa liberté pour plus de
sécurité ne mérite ni l'un ni
l'autre je sais mais ça demande ça
demanderait une réponse plus approfondie
parce que est-ce que je suis prêt à
à oui je je si tu veux ça me dérange pas
qui est dans des moments comme ça qui a
des des un état d'urgence on est dans un
dans un mais il faut pas que ça
s'éternise il faut pas que des gens
l'utilisent et puis il a une nécessité
de l'enquête je sais pas enfin je est-ce
que tu as lu la stratégie du choc de
Naomie cl non j'ai le bouquin je l'ai
pas lu je vais je vais le relire je vais
le l je connais le thème je je connais
ce que je te propose sur ce sujet là on
passer un autre sujet je te réinviterai
une fois que tu auras lu ce bouquin non
je je te promets en plus je l'ai chez
moi tu vois mais j'ai des piles de
livres chez moi et et il s'aligne là je
suis en train de lire
euh je suis en train de lire nocturnne
indien mais c'est n'a rien à voir mais
bon on va on va on va passer à auprès
des des on va passer aux préconisations
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que tu peux
préconiser au aux jeunes qui nous
écoutent dans dans dans l'air qui est en
train de sa temps il y a une
augmentation des risques il y a les
signaux faibles qui sont t so rouges une
caste politique qui est de plus en plus
soit incompétente soit qui réagit dans
l'émotion soit d'une façon symptomatique
un journaliste qui a 16 ans tu lui
conseilles quoi là ça y est il il a 16
ans il veut être journaliste [__] la
question que tu me poses mais non non
non mais moi j'ai j'ai trois j'ai un
fils qui a qui vient d'avoir 11 ans j'ai
une fille qui a 22 ans et sa sœur qui a
26 ans donc
mon fils j'ai l'impression que ça lui
est passé un peu au-dessus j'essaie d'en
parler avec lui mais ça l'intéresse pas
euh enfin il était pas conscient de je
pense qu'il est matraqué en permanence
par par ces trucs et que ça crée une
angoisse chez lui euh et donc on en
parle un peu comme ça et comment tu fais
pour aborder les choses mais moi
j'aiécrit un livre qui s'appelle vue
imprenable sur la folie du monde et
c'est le le thème de la c'est l'histoire
d'un père et d'un fils qui se balade
c'est comme un r movie et et je et si tu
veux en substance ce que je dis c'est
que l'éduquer en tout cas être son père
c'est à la fois le protéger mais sans le
rendre parano et qui continue à avoir
confiance aux autres mais en même temps
qu'il soi pas naïf qu'il se fasse pas
avoir c'est très compliqué cette
attitude à avoir par rapport à l'autre
c'estàdire que soit tu deviens frond
national ou complètement barré ou
d'ailleurs
même au PS il a y a des discours comme
ça tu as une grande méfiance qui
s'installe excuse-moi la la je t'écoute
entendre Front national barré terroriste
AINS suite nous on a un point de vue
anthropologique sur les choses c'estàd
que on regarde les choses en face certes
les déviances violentes que ce soit
l'armée américaine l'armée française ou
toute déviance militaire pour nous on a
un regard anthropologique vas-y continue
excuse-moi de t'avoir coupé non mais là
tu me tu tu me posais la question de de
de de du discours à avoir par rapport à
des gens plus jeunes quoi d'abord je
suis pas un moraliste j'ai peu de leçons
à donner mais en tout cas je vis au
contact par mes enfants et puis par
leurs amis et cetera et donc c'est voilà
l'attitude à avoir c'est c'est mais tout
tout ça ne repose que sur l'information
c'est-à-dire que que il faut que ces ces
personnes quel que soit leur âge
s'informe lise mais mon mom de 11 ans a
une certaine réticence à la lecture
comme comme beaucoup donc c'est il est
beaucoup sur Internet il est beaucoup
sur les sites et et je crois que
l'information on la trouve sur internet
aujourd'hui mais on trouve on trouve on
trouve tout et n'importe quoi il les les
thèses comment tu fais tu fais pour
gérer ça quand tu as un gamin de 11 ans
qui a une maîtrise de l'ordinateur qui
doit être deux fois supérieure à la
tienne et c'est pas encore ça
va qui est-ce que tu as un filtre
parental sur son ordinateur est-ce que
tu lui as pris est-ce que tu lui as
appris à surfer est-ce que tu lui as
appris à reconnaîre lui je regarde un
peu sur quoi il surf parce que je
contrôle s'il a un iPad je je tombe
dessus quoi j'ai remarqué d'ailleurs
qu'il est dans un certain nombre de jeux
avec sa PS et don et don de trucs et qui
communique beaucoup euh il dialogue sur
des messageries et cetera je regarde pas
ce qu'il dit mais en général il va sur
des sites de basket lui de sport et des
choses comme ça donc il est pas trop euh
et s'il se radicalisait ton gamin tu
ferais quoi je pense qu'il je parlerai
avec lui quoi il y a que le dialogue il
y a que l'information mais je pense
qu'on l'a on l'a éduqué de telle sorte
que euh est ouvert à plein de choses qui
se radicalisera pas quoi parce qu'il est
pas je peux je peux me permettre de me
mettre dans la tête de ton fils une
seule seconde si tu m'autorise oui je
t'en prie ton fils il grandit il
commence à s'intéresser au bouquin que
tu as pu faire il va regarder ton film
l'enquête il voit que son père a été
persécuté pendant des années pour une
cause qui était juste et que
heureusement que son père avait un grand
cœur une grosse tête et surtout une
bonne tête brûlé il a résisté jusqu'à
tout ça ça a été David contre Goliath et
de ses amis subit la même chose et il
décide de prendre les
armes tu fais quoi d'abord il me
demandera pas l'autorisation il me dira
rien décide non mais je je sais pas
comment comment dire je sais pas comment
tout ça va évoluer mais si
ça si
ça on est obligé de s'interroger sur la
question des armes aujourd'hui parce que
si ça continue à à se pourrir un peu
comme c'est en train de se pourrir euh
peut-être qu'on sera obligé de les
prendre les armes c'est la pire la le
dernier recours mais à un moment donné
si on on on atteinte on porte atteinte à
ma liberté ou à ma manière de de vivre
d'être mon athéisme par exemple où on
m'oblige et tout je me défendrai quoi
enfin tu vois et à un moment donné la
défense ultime c'est ça quoi qu'est-ce
que tu veux je veux
dire tu tu penses pas que la défense
ultime c'est faut être deux pour se
battre non mais on en est pas là mais là
tu es en train de de d'imaginer un
scénar noir quoi mais je pense qu'au
moment de la résistance là mon prochain
film mon prochain documentaire va être
j'ai ça fait un moment que j'y pense
mais je vais vraiment le faire là ça
être le portrait d'une d'une femme
admirable qui a 93 ans qui a résisté
pendant la
guerre
qui elle s'appelle Anne Le Manoir merci
et elle est elle a résisté pendant la
guerre et et puis après elle elle a
soutenu le le FLN en Algérie elle est
devenue c'était elle est devenue un des
une des premières elle était secrétaire
d'État du premier gouvernement algérien
elle a un parcours elle a un parcours
incroyable elle est absolument inconnue
du grand public et et j'ai très envie de
faire ce film avec elle
euh elle le sait mais simplement j'ai
pas encore trouvé le temps et le le ce
film
prend de l'acé aujourd'hui avec ce qui
se passe quoi parce que la question à se
poser c'est comment résister comment
être résistant comment rester cette
conscience éveillée comment ne pas
croire tout ce qu'on nous dit comment ne
pas s'emballer voilà mais moi ces
questions là je me les pose quoi mais en
permanence si tu veux je lis beaucoup de
choses là-dessus je lis des textes j'ai
des amis qui sont mais mais hyper
remontés contre contre l'islam j'ai
d'ailleurs j'ai relu un peu le Coran ces
derniers ces derniers temps ce que
j'avais jamais fait je trouve que le
Coran est hyper violent le le le Coran
je m'étais pas j'ava m'étais pas rendu
compte de parce que tu as lu la Bible
j'ai lu la Bible mais la Bible mais je
l' lu mais rapidement j'ai pas lu la
Torah mais rapidement si tu veux cette
lecture m'épuise he je préfère lire des
romans et lire mais là là si tu veux je
par rapport à l'interprétation qui est
faite du du du Coran j'essaie de
comprendre et
donc c'est Nina ma fille qui qui disait
ça et qui m'a il y a des trucs qui m'ont
qui
m'ont je trouve que euh la manière dont
le Coran traite les mécréants c'est
quand même un peu particulier la Bible
la Bible n'a l'air d'être un peu plus
douce à cet égard même sil y a des sces
très violentes rappelle l'Inquisition
oui mais c'est autre chose mais enfin
écoute en tout cas quand tu vois la
manière dont se justifient les les
attentats tout tout est justifié par par
le Coran et par par l'Islam et alors
j'ai une tas d'amis musulmans qui sont
hyper modérés enfin et cetera mais il y
a un vrai problème j'ai des discussions
avec eux mais mais un autre un autre
problème c'est la manière dont ne sont
pas gérés les les les mosquées en France
quoi et c'est terrible sont pas géré
bien sûr que si elles sont gérées on se
fait acheter de l'intérieur on se fait
acheter de l'Intérieur ensuite il y a
aucune formation d'imam en France de ce
nom et ensuite les imams salafistes
issus de l'islam la plus rigoriste tu
sais d'où ça vient ah c'est un cercle
vicieux après bien sûr mais mais là la
la responsabilité de rappellei
rappelle-moi quel est le le sponsor du
PSG oui non mais je je vois où tu vas en
venir mais là je veux je on peut aller
sur ce terrainlà mais ça la
responsabilité de l'État dis-moi oui
c'est ça c'est-à-dire que le le ministre
de l'Intérieur et aussi le ministre des
Cultes donc là ça suffit il faut les
fermer les mosquées ces mosquées là si
les musulmans sont pas capable de de de
de se gérer entre eux il y a cette cette
grande permissivité et cetera euh c'est
plus possible de laisser euh c'est c'est
c'est c'estes qu quand on les a repéré
il faut les fermer quoi et puis voilà à
un moment moment donné il faut arrêter
avec les bons sentiments il faut les
faut les avoir ces sentiments mais il y
a une il y a donc tu peux plus
accepter à l'intérieur de de dis-moi ce
que tu en penses mais peut-on l'accepter
que que des mecs balancent ses ses ces
discours horribles euh sur les femmes
sur la musique sur les enfants et et ce
qui a terrible et d'ailleurs c'est ce
qui m'inquiète le plus c'est la manière
parce que là on est on est sur une
génération de terroristes les momes ont
20 ans là tu en avais un qui avait 15
ans mais il y a tous les momes euh qui
sont déjà EMB brigadé qui aujourd'hui
ont 4 5 6 ans et qui n'ont vécu qu'avec
des images de décapitation et cetera
c'est que bombes sur la tête ouais ou
que des bombes sur la tête ouais et donc
j'ai vu un un je sais plus sur quel j'ai
vu ça sur internet mais ça venait d'une
chaîne de télé un mom de 3 ans ou 4 ans
qui avait été récupéré par sa famille et
qui pleurait tout le temps parce que son
père l'avait étit à daesh et et lui
avait fait voir et assisté à des décapit
et il voyait ça à longueur de journée et
le MOM était drogué par ses images
violentes et il pleurait et dès qu'on
lui mettait la télé avec l'image de de
décapitation il se calmait mais tu vois
ce que ça signifie si tu en as si tu en
as des milliers comme ça je je vais
répondre à ta question en deux fois la
première pour comprendre la psychologie
des enfants de guerre bah je te
conseille le film de de matthie kassovit
qui traite sur ce sujet là et pour
répondre à ta question je je t'invite à
aller sur internet et aller voir une
conférence de Krishna Murti à u en
1985 sur la paix dans le monde et sur
qui quel livre comment ça se passe et
peut-être avoir qu'est-ce que tu penses
de chrishna Murti ah mais Krishna Murti
moi il m'a il m'a fondé donc j'ai pas en
tête cette conférence
mais le livre que j'ai le plus offert
dans ma vie mais quand j'ai dû en offrir
25ucation c'est de l'amour et de la
solitude on est sur un autre sujet mais
Krishna morti est une est une est un
type qui enfin moi j'ai lu ça avec
passion j'ai j'ai plein de livres de lui
d'ailleurs ça fait un moment que j'ai
parmi le Nant mais je regarderai cette
cette conférence c'est vrai que ces
paroles de sagesse d'ailleurs dans le
bouddhisme et dans le
dans tu vois c'est une religion qui à
part je trouve qu' a une plus grande
tolérance et je suis je suis pas
bouddhiste hein mais mais enfin on n'est
pas loin avec chrishnaamti donc
peut-être la la la sagesse elle est
là-bas quoi j'ai une dernière question
pour toi oui euh
c'est compliqué de poser la derre
question chaque fois celle d'avant était
était
raide donne-moi un conseil alors que
pour notre équipe donne-nous un conseil
pour pour notre équipe un un conseil
comme ça pour pour la création de pour
nous moi je je trouve que ce que vous
faites et c'est pour ça que je suis là
c'est c'est c'est c'est vraiment vous
avez une intelligence un regard en plus
tu es pas de la même génération que ceux
qui sont avec toi non mais c'est
vraiment de continuer de mais j'ai même
pas de conseil à vous donner vous êtes
vous avez l'air suffisamment comment
dire éveillé pour mais on a on a besoin
de n'écoutez pas le regard des autres
faites ce que vous avez en tête et puis
et et
restez une conscience éveillée quoi et
et réfléchissez par vous-même en vous
informant au maximum quoi denier Robert
merci c'est moi c conseils pour la
jeunesse
donc comment blanchir de l'argent sans
se faire choper alors ça c'est facile ça
je peux vous dire j'aime bien il y a il
y a une phrase de d'un juge que j'avais
interviewé qui s'appelle Balthazar
Garson qui est un juge espagnol qui
m'avait
dit je comprends pas les braqueurs
aujourd'hui qui prennent tellement de
risque à braquer des des banques alors
que c'est si facile d'acheter une banque
ça coûte rien donc mon conseil si vous
voulez blanchir de l'argent vous allez
aujourd'hui peut-être aux île Fidji où
on peut acheter des banques pour pas
grand-chose vous créez une banque
ensuite vous lui mettez de l'argent et
tout le problème de cette banque c'est
de rentrer dans le circuit et et il faut
arriver à un endroit qui s'appelle la
chambre de compensation internationale
c'est tout le thème de mon enquête sur
classream et cette banque avec cette
banque vous allez prendre un banquier
dans cette banque vous allez payer comme
vous êtes très riche vous avez beaucoup
d'argent à blanchir il faut que le
banquier soit soit plutôt euh beau mec
ou même une nana une banquière avec un
bien sapé et cetera et puis il faut que
cette banque dal avec une autre banque
donc si vous êtes aux ilî Fidji vous
allez aller en Australie par exemple
vous allez trouver une banque
australienne euh mais la banque
australienne va va savoir que l'argent
est un peu pourri mais comme vous
laissez un petit peu de commission elle
va elle va accepter votre deal elle va
accepter votre argent vous avez franchi
une première étape ensuite cette banque
il faut qu'elle s'approche comme je vous
disais de la chambre de compensation une
fois qu'elle sera dedans ça sera très
facile votre argent sera blanchi
c'est-à-dire que il faut rentrer dans ce
circuit-là une chambre de compensation
c'est un conglomérat on va dire bancaire
où on achète on vend euh des devises des
actions des obligations ensemble et
cetera une fois que vous rentrez dans ce
circuit-là c'est bon vous pouvez
ressortir de l'argent où vous voulez et
vous créez un circuit qui est euh
Intraçable euh euh jusqu'à ce que un
contrôle se fasse sur ce type de circuit
et un de mes grands de mes grands
combats c'était ça c'était de faire
connaître ces pratiques là et de faire
en sorte que des contrôleurs puissent
contrôler tout ça mais pour l'instant
c'est tranquille vous pouvez y aller
même avec daesh ils ont pas encore ils
ont pas encore contrôlé et c'est comme
ça que daesh d'ailleurs se
finance je suis long non euh je dois
m'abonner à MDI partou Charlie
Hebdo il faut vraiment choisir entre les
deux si couteau sous la
gorge
miapart c'est quoi la meilleure école
pour devenir
whistleblower bah c'est euh c'est
l'école de la vie quoi c'est con ce que
je vais dire mais euh voilà c'est tout
c'est c'est à un moment donné si vous
êtes cette conscience éveillée la
douleur que vous fait l'injustice est
plus forte que tout et donc faut vous
arranger pour pour pour balancer faut
euh après faut être malin quoi c'est pas
forcément se se se mettre se mettre
devant aujourd'hui il la mes aventures
que vit le Antoine Deltour qui est qui
est le le jeune auditeur qui a balancé
les informations de lux lex aujourd'hui
il est mis en examen au Luxembourg ce
qui est quand même infernal quoi et donc
et son seul péché est
d'avoir informer un un journaliste euh
et il est resté dans l'ombre et à un
moment donné euh euh il est apparu et
donc le il est poursuivi par la la
société d'audit et lui ce qu'il a
dénoncé c'est comment des
multinationales comme Amazon Ikea Google
et cetera ne payez pas d'impôt alors que
nous on en paye ce type il faudrait lui
décerner la la la Légion d'honneur lui
donner une bourse à vie et et il
faudrait que que François Hollande lui
déroule le tapis rouge à l'Élysée mais
mais tu vois il est il est il est il est
poursuivi pour avoir dit la vérité donc
il y a il y a il y a encore vraiment du
du du travail quoi mais je pense qu'il
est plus heureux aujourd'hui malgré tout
parce qu'il a fait ça et parce que c'est
un héros quoi et qu' vaut mieux être un
héros qu'un qu'un type
soumis C auteurs à lire pour être malin
genre chumski guide debor je crois que
vous l'avez cité oui alors après tu tu
peux choisir mais moi je préfère
toujours la littérature c'està-dire que
j'apprends beaucoup plus de choses en
lisant des des
romans que
qu'en lisant noem schomski j'ai adoré
lire noem shomski mais ce qui m'a formé
le plus c'est de c'est c'est de alors
ces gens-là m'ont formé mais moi par
exemple le livre qui m'a le premier
livre que j'ai lu al indépendamment de
Cavana de tout quand j'étais adolescent
mais qui m'a donné envie de d'écrire ce
que j'écris c'est Truman capotte de s
froid qui est le voilà c'est la première
fois que je vous ce livre va changer ma
vie après il y a il y a tous les livres
de Richard brotigan qui est un américain
que peut-être vous connaissez pas mais
il faut lire imprivé à Babylone ou il
faut lire la vengeance de la pelouse et
et derrière lui derrière derrière
derrière lui il y a John Fante il y a
Charles Bukovski il y a tous ces gens-là
euh après si si on est dans les dans les
auteurs plus
politiques noem schomski effectivement
mais plus regarder ses conférences ou
ces films que ses livre parce que c'est
pas quelqu'un qui écrit formidablement
c'est un orateur c'est quelqu'un qui
c'est une puissance intellectuelle mais
ces livres sont assez chiants me
semble-t-il sauf celui que j'ai fait
avec lui qui s'appelle 2 heures de
lucidité puisque j'ai je suis un des
premiers en France en tout cas avoir
fait un livre d'entretien avec Noam
shomski donc faut lire 2 heures de de de
lucidité et puis puis voilà quoi
qu'est-ce que je peux te conseiller
d'autres moi j'ai relu Carl Marx
récemment je trouve ça je suis pas
communiste mais je suis marxiste c'estàd
que il y a toujours une une son analyse
des classes sociales et cetera reste à
mes yeux vraiment pertinentes quoi et
puis
euh euh qu'est-ce que je lis je lis en
ce moment David Foster Wallas qui est un
écrivain américain qui s'est suicidé
récemment et qui
est qui a écrit un livre que j'ai
commencé mais il fait 1000 pages ça
s'appelle l'infini comédie et je je sais
que cet été très bientôt je vais lire ça
voilà je t'ai donné quelques
livres il faut lire les commentaires
pour la société du spectacle de guide de
bord plus que la société du spectacle
c'est plus accessible c'est sorti en
poche ça coûte rien il a fait en film
aussi c'est pas mal ouais les films sont
un peu chiant mais mais ça peut mais
ouais c'est du situationnisme relou
c'est quoi le kit du journalisme du
journaliste intègre le le kit du
journaliste intègre qu'est-ce qu' met
dans sa
valise tu sais il met pas grandchose il
arrive avec sa [__] et son couteau quoi
c'est un peu ça le
le en général il faut incarner un stylo
euh
mais je je reprends Troman capotte quand
il écrit quand il écrit de sang froid
son son son livre il a écrit qu'un seul
livre intéressant c'est les autres sont
c'est vraiment un livre important de
sangfroid parce que on est dans un fait
diviver américain qui est un
l'assassinat d'une famille euh et lui il
retrace le parcours de des assassins et
euh et on est vraiment dans la tête des
assassins quoi et Troman quand il écrit
ce bouquin il prend pas il a il prend il
a pris aucune note c'était un mec qui
prenait tout le temps des notes parce
qu'il était journaliste et il a fait
travailler sa mémoire il a mis 12 ans à
écrire entre le moment où où il y a le
fait divhiver et le moment où le livre
sort
et à un moment donné quand tu as
confiance en toi
euh tu te rends compte que c'est ta
mémoire qui fait le tri et et et et tu
écris quoi mais mais c'est quand tu es
écrivain moi j'ai une définition assez
particulière du du journalisme quand tu
es journaliste
il aujourd'hui en tout cas d'abord il
faut être web journaliste c'est-à-dire
que tu peux plus être que sur le papier
évidemment et il faut être le plus
précis le plus rigoureux le plus curieux
possible et il faut toujours donner la
parole à ceux que tu mets en cause c'est
la première chose à faire tu es pas là
pour régler des comptes tu es là pour
approcher d'un truc qui s'appelle la
vérité quoi euh et et j'avais un
problème avec ça pendant longtemps parce
que j'avais du mal à en parler parce que
la vérité c'est un concept un peu
religieux et cetera mais non la vérité
c'était une discussion que j'avais eu
avec Noam schomski d'ailleurs Noam
shomski m'avait dit tu vois cette table
elle est noir tu peux pas me dire que
c'est pas une table et qu'elle est pas
noir c'est ça la vérité c'est aussi con
que ça quoi donc à un moment il faut il
faut pas les lâcher quoi les types
veulent pas vous répondre en général un
type qui veut pas vous répondre c'est un
type qui a quelque chose à cacher et
donc le rôle d'un journaliste c'est
d'aller d'aller dévoiler c'est pas être
un délateur mais généralement quand un
type a quelque chose à cacher sauf si
c'est quelque chose d'intime évidemment
c'est pas le problème mais généralement
c'est pas voilà il faut aller au bout et
puis à un moment donné il y il y a le
moment de l'écriture quoi donc un
journaliste il faut qu'il sur son kit à
part un carnet un stylo un Magnetto une
caméra maintenant il faut être un peu
Chiva quoi il faut avoir une une grande
pugnacité quoi ok plutôt DST ou
DGS plutôt D ou DGSE DGS sil fallait
choisir d séries tu veux dire de le
aujourd'hui le système qui a aujourd'hui
ou le système d'avant c'est ça que tu
veux tu veux dire non mais j'ai j'ai
l'impression que que le le le système
qui a été mis en place qui veut réunir
un peu tout le monde fonctionne pas très
bien quoi
euh d'un autre côté les les
renseignements généraux comme ils
existaient fonctionnent pas non plus
quoi
donc mais tout le probl problème reste
le le
contrôle démocratique donc par
l'Assemblée nationale de ces outils de
renseignement et il faut jamais oublier
qu'un pouvoir politique peut changer
quoi et donc c'est ces systèmes
policiers que tu mets en place et que tu
crées un jour peuvent être être aux
mains de de de gens qui qui pensent pas
comme toi et qui peuvent les utiliser
contre toi donc c'est un peu compliqué
euh contrairement à ENF c'est ce que je
disais tout à l'heure dans l'entretien
que je faisais quoi moi je dans un état
non dans ce qui nous arrive en ce moment
en France il faut absolument un un un
service de
renseignement qui
soit qui soit intelligent et qui soit
très énervé dans le pays pour essayer de
comprendre et de savoir et à l'extérieur
aussi quoi donc ça demande ça demande
beaucoup de beaucoup de travail beaucoup
de d'expérience et beaucoup de sangfroid
ben merci beaucoup Dony Robert ben merci
à toi Carmen
[Musique]